Okay, so to begin our conversation this
evening, insha'Allah, we'll start with
Dr. Zakir Naik. So, Dr. Zakir Naik, to
set the scene and to give some context
to this topic, what reform would you
want in the way of the ummah
in the modern world today when it comes
to following the Sunnah?
Alhamdulillah. As-salatu was-salam ala
Rasulillah wa ala alihi wa sahbihi
ajma'in. Amma ba'd. A'udhu billahi min
ash-shaytani rajim. Bismillahir Rahmanir
Rahim. Rabbi shrahli sadri wa yassirli
amri wahlul uqdatan min lisani yafqahu
qawli. I welcome all of you with the
Islamic greeting as-salamu alaykum wa
rahmatullahi wa barakatuh. May peace,
mercy, and blessings of Allah subhanahu
wa ta'ala be on all of you.
Regarding what reform I would want for
the present ummah in today's time, of
course we had the 2-day conference and
all what the speakers said is relevant
to it.
But, I would like to focus on one point
that's very important in reform.
Of course, we cannot reform the Sunnah.
The Sunnah is the same. We have to go
back to the original Sunnah.
But, reforming the present ummah,
today,
even if we agree that we'll not go on
that point where Muslims are not
following Sunnah. I would like to go to
that part of the ummah where Muslims are
following Sunnah.
What reform I like?
First, number one, the Muslim should be
aware that amongst the Sunnah, which is
the most important Sunnah? He should
first try to do the most important
Sunnah.
If he cannot do,
then the second best. Or if he wants to
do five Sunnahs in any particular act,
I'll come to it. He should try and do
the best.
For example, the first question Allah
will ask you on the day of judgment is
about your deeds and about your salah.
The most important Sunnah amongst all
the Sunnah after the fard is
which is the most important Sunnah?
The most important Sunnah after the fard
is
English. Anyone tell me?
Which is the most important Sunnah?
Number one Sunnah after doing all your
minimum fard is
that you have to do.
The most important Sunnah according to
me
is Tahajjud prayer.
The most important deed is salah.
After you complete your five time salah,
the most important Sunnah salah
is
Tahajjud prayer. If you want to offer
any Sunnah
in salah, you should first try and offer
Tahajjud prayer.
And the best time to offer in the last
third
of the night. If you cannot, then you
offer it in the early part after your
Isha salah.
The most important according to me and
according to the Hadith
is
Tahajjud prayer.
If it's coupled with Tahajjud salah, you
get up in the
last one third of the night and pray
your salah. It was fard for the prophet,
not for the ummah.
For us, it's mustahab.
And for a da'ee,
it is more important.
So, if a Muslim comes and tells me, "I
want to offer Sunnah salah."
"I will offer the two rak'ah
after wudu."
Is it a Sunnah? Yes.
We know the Hadith of Muhammad talking
about Bilal, may Allah be pleased with
him. I don't want to go into the detail.
It is a Sunnah. But, if someone says, "I
want to offer the Sunnah." It's good.
I'm not against it. But, if you're going
to offer only one Sunnah salah, which is
the most important?
Tahajjud prayer.
Along with Tahajjud.
Okay, I cannot offer Tahajjud.
I cannot wake up in the middle. Okay,
offer the witr
after Isha. The next important Sunnah
is the Sunnah before the Fajr salah, two
rak'ah. Our beloved prophet said, "The
two rak'ah Sunnah before the Fajr is
more valuable than the world and the
wealth in it."
Imagine.
So, which is more important, the two
rak'ah after wudu or two rak'ah before
the Fajr salah? So, if you know the
importance of
the Sunnah salah, you first try and do
the most important Sunnah. And by any
way you cannot do, then try and do the
second best, then the third best. So, in
salah, the most important is Tahajjud
prayer. Tahajjud is the best.
Next important Sunnah
is the two rak'ah
before the Fajr salah. Then,
is the Sunnah mu'akkadah.
Which the two rak'ah Sunnah before Fajr
is included. Then, the two plus two
before the Dhuhr salah, two after the
salah, two after the Maghrib salah, and
two after the Isha salah.
So, first you follow the highly
recommended Sunnah,
then the recommended Sunnah, then the
Sunnah.
Sunnah can be divided into three
broad types, if you want. Highly
recommended,
and only Sunnah.
Then, which is the recommended Sunnah?
The prophet said
of
salat ad-duha. I won't go into the
details. I'm in short.
So, next if you want to offer after
offering
the Sunnah mu'akkadah, which are 12
rak'ah in a day, salat ad-duha.
These are all highly recommended Sunnah.
Which is the next recommended Sunnah?
There are many recommended Sunnah. I'll
just pick up one which has come to my
mind. It is tahiyyatul masjid.
The prophet in the Jumu'ah salah, there
is no Sunnah before Jumu'ah salah. While
giving khutbah, he saw a sahabi coming
and sitting. He stopped his khutbah and
asked him, "Did you offer your two
rak'ah tahiyyatul masjid?" He said,
"No." He said, "Stand up and offer."
It's a recommended Sunnah.
Not as highly recommended as Tahajjud
prayer
or the two rak'ah before Fajr.
Then, the other Sunnah
is Sunnah ghair mu'akkadah, in which the
prophet missed without any reason.
So, if you want to offer salah, go in
order. If you cannot do for certain
reason, go to next. Offering two rak'ah
after wudu is good. I'm not against it.
But, more important are the more
important Sunnah and then you can go to
that.
So, if you know the order of the Sunnah,
which is more important,
you will get more thawab
and more chances of entering Jannah and
more chances of washing away your sins.
Then, you can offer the other salah
whether you're leaving your house,
entering the house, then you do
two rak'ah.
All these are Sunnah, but more important
for Muslim knows which is more
important. He tries and does the most
important, then the second, then the
third. Let me give you one more example.
My staff in Malaysia,
he does, alhamdulillah, religiously
the third important pillar, which is
sawm. He does his fasting on Monday and
Thursday, religiously, masha'Allah. Very
good. Alhamdulillah. But, then I find
that he's not doing the other more
important fasting. Fasting is a fard for
every Muslim in the month of Ramadan.
Besides Ramadan, it's not a fard.
But, someone is fasting on Monday,
Thursday, very good.
But, then he's not offering
the fasting
of the
first nine days of Dhul-Hijjah. Maybe
only one, but not the first eight days.
So, which is the most important fasting
after the fasting of Ramadan?
It is the fasting on Arafah.
I won't go into the references. It will
take time. Our prophet said, "If you
fast on the day of Arafah, two years
sins will be forgiven."
Which is the second most important
Sunnah fast?
It is fasting on Ashura,
the 10th of Muharram.
Arafah is the ninth of Dhul-Hijjah.
Then is the 10th of Muharram. The
prophet said, "If you fast in Ashura,
your one year sin will be forgiven."
If you add up both, technically, one
year is not overlapping. It's not It's
three years.
One year sin of the last year
and the
next year.
When you come
to Muharram, the year changes.
And Hadith says one year sin. So, if you
add up
both together, it is three years sin
are forgiven. So, the second most
important is fasting on the 10th day
of Muharram, Ashura.
Then, which is important? Then, the
first eight days
of Dhul-Hijjah. The prophet said, "Any
deed done
in these 10 days of Dhul-Hijjah,
it is better than any other deeds."
Sahaba asked him, "Even better than
jihad?" He said, "Yes. Even better than
jihad, unless you go and you die in the
battlefield and give up all your wealth.
That is the only deed better."
So, amongst the good deed, if you fast
on the first eight days, ninth day is
already covered by me, on the day of
Arafah. It is more important than the
other fasting. So, if you know the
order,
if you want to fast,
fast those which are more important.
Then, you have
the ayyamul bid,
the three white days, 13th, 14th, and
15th of every
month.
Then, you have the days of Shawwal, six
days.
Now, difference of opinion which is
Shawwal is Some scholars say more better
than ayyamul bid. But, the first three
orders,
there's no difference of opinion.
Then, you can come on Monday and
Thursday. And
today,
while meet and greet, the question came
on fasting and asked him, "Which is the
most important Sunnah fasting?" He said,
"Monday, Thursday."
It's good. I'm not against fasting. But,
if you're not keeping the one day fast
which will forgive your two years sins,
a one day fast which will forgive your
one year sins,
so if you know your priorities of the
Sunnah, you will get more thawab.
Any Sunnah, you will get thawab.
But,
you should know
which is more important. So, of course,
the salah is more important, then comes
fasting. In fasting, which fasting is
more important? People come and tell me,
"I like sweet dish. It's Sunnah."
You think sweet dish is Sunnah? Of
course. The prophet loved sweet dishes.
But, the brother is not saying bismillah
before eating food.
Saying bismillah before eating food is a
more priority of Sunnah than eating
sweet dishes.
So, I would request the ummah today,
especially in the modern era, who's
following the Sunnah, do a little bit
research
which of the Sunnah is more important
and try and do the more important Sunnah
if it's impossible
to do all the Sunnah. And when I told
the brother
the brother, do you know that the
prophet never fasted every Monday and
Thursday? He got the shock of his life.
It's a Sunnah to fast on Monday and
Thursday, but the prophet never fasted
every Monday and every Thursday.
But the brother is doing it.
It's good you can do it.
Alhamdulillah, but you do the more
important
Sunnah. So, in less Sunnah you get more
reward.
So, if we do a little research that
which Sunnah is more highly recommended,
which is recommended, which is
only a Sunnah. Inshallah, the chances
that you go to Jannah is high.
Jazakallah khair. Masha Allah. Baraka
Allahu fikum. One big takeaway from that
is prioritization. We only have so much
time in a day and try to pick, as you
said Dr. Zakir Naik, the ones which have
more priority and more reward with less
effort. Right? That's being efficient
and productive. Masha Allah. And to do
that, of course, it requires some
knowledge. It requires for us to know
what the priorities are. So, what this
is leading towards when it comes to this
conversation is that when we talk about
reform, before we speak about reform of
the Ummah, it starts with reforming
ourselves first.